you
[Music]
hello everyone one of the elbonia my
name is Vicente and I'm so one in a year
manager at the Liberty hero and I will
show you basically what my team has been
doing for the last one and a half years
basically we've been building a data
pipeline in order for data consumers
within the company to consume the data
in real time or seen different in other
two ways I'll show you a couple of
slides but yeah our main focus was the
real-time okay so some key facts about
the company just to understand was the
business environment so they'll be here
was founded in 2011 operating in 40-plus
markets and employing more than 70
thousand people is the largest food
network in the world of the apps with
more than 200,000 restaurants online you
went public in 2017 and in 2018 reached
the 1 million orders in one day
and as per July this year we process
more than 2 million orders on a single
day now in regards of data so in the
Liberty hero only four order related
events or data we are processing
birthday more than 2 million events on
top of that you have to add the user
data the vendor updates logistics the
information so many more events you can
imagine is a business operating him
quite a lot of markets and with this an
amount of volume to process also to
understand how the company is organized
and that will lead to why our team
started one way of grouping delivery
hero is
there are on one side the branch that
our team's building services that
deliver the food to the customers that
get the orders from the customers and
there are many brands around the world
or quite so for instance opana is
operating in a park Europe
mium in Austria Tala but in Middle East
and these different brands have their
own tech teams with their own databases
with their own ways of defining what's
an order and they don't relate to each
other right they are different type of
information and on the other hand we
have Global Services something that you
can imagine as a micro or macro service
that provides functionality for this
brand so for instance we have logistics
global service we have recommendations
global service we have assert so and
they are independent right an order in
logistics is completely different than
an order in food mana and so on so then
was a challenge of this approach the
challenges that if food panel wants to
integrate or use certain logistics and
certain logistics needs the order then
food mana has to send the order as it
understands the order to these two
services right if the leaders are a
brand operating in South America wants
to also use these three services the
same has to happen again right so it's
again another connections and in the
data may be in different format to these
services and so on so you can imagine
that we are replicating several clients
around the network they are sending
maybe same data to different services at
the same time and that's why we have
started our team and we started building
date of it is how we call our data
pipeline and then was a mission of data
fridge the our mission was to unify the
data across
these brands to provide an date this
data in at least three different ways in
a real-time manner in a low latency
restful api so the consumers could pull
this data and also in a high latency or
Maria analytical processing waiting with
the consumers maybe could run analytical
queries and process this data and
obviously given that we we have already
data unified in data feeds it makes
sense to also build the machine learning
applications on top of that because then
the machine learning teams don't need to
write algorithms for each of these
orders from each of these brands and
they can just run the algorithm to war
based on singular model and it's more
efficient India so what's the
architecture that we went for data fleet
so any producer will send the data to an
ingestion API so the data will be in
certain format and will be valid then it
will be pushed to the swimming part
simian service and from the streaming
service there will be different event
subscriptions one for the real-time
consumers there will be another
subscription for a story in this event
in the storage that is needed for the
low latency API and there will be
another subscription in order to store
this data in database that can process
or that can process these analytical
queries so one ingestion point for any
of the brands and three different ways
that we can provide to the consumers to
consume this data okay let's start with
the first component so the ingestion API
very simple just we are using API
gateway and lambda you will see that we
are using a lot of it earlier
but I will try to give an analogy with
open-source components so IP a good way
on lambda is just an abstraction of
maybe some it restful api basically that
you can run open source so what's the in
the mission or why we have this ingest
an api is to make sure that they data
follows certain schema and that the data
is valid
basically so because as I said the
already been from the different brands
are different so we need to make sure
that they are the same
so at ingestion we verify they have to
send the data in the format that we
specify and besides ingesting the data
for their real time event we also
provide or we also use this in just an
API for doing a sink of the data so if
they want to send all the restaurants
for Center certain country they can also
do it from one of these endpoints and we
use for security and authentication I
think decision would use a people listen
and GWT nothing very fancy now in
regards of the deployment because I
think this is a bit interesting so we
are using current employment that is
provided by Amazon and the reason to
doing so is in order to reduce the
amount of data loss the way we are the
planet is every time we have a release
for our ingestion API we start rolling
out traffic to this new release and
checking matrix in the meantime and that
allows us to reduce the amount of data
loss if we will deploy a brown release
on production or if we would deploy a
release that we think the data will be
fine in the environment in the
production environment and that's not
the case so that's why current
employment we decided to go for current
employment so we deploy a new release
and we start routing traffic to it
checking the matrix giving more traffic
and in the end giving a hundred percent
if something goes wrong then we we roll
back
okay now the stream empire of the
architecture box so once the data is on
the ingestion API the lambda writes the
data into kenosis
AWS kinases is same as Kafka why we use
kinases because we can have as a storage
can use it as as as I saw that in case
some data is lost on the last thing on
the dance - in size so kinases allows us
to store data for seven days and we can
be played if something goes wrong and
also kinases scales have gone down so
that's not an issue from kinases now we
have a lambda that is medium from there
and pushing to SNS SNS is message bus
provided by Amazon I don't think that is
good analogy on the open source maybe
pops up on Google Cloud
may be pumped up or not other services
but it's basically you push a message to
tweet and if there is any consumer
subscribe to this topic SNS will push to
the consumer immediately and then the
consumers understand aside so you might
wonder why we have kinases on SNS why
the consumers are not just reading from
a kinases as many of the services I have
seen the first reason is first of all we
don't care about the order of the events
in something that the consumer has have
to deal with it
as I saw you there is an ingestion API
and the clients are multi thread clients
they are putting the data in parallel
via HTTP requests and things and events
can come out of order so the fact that
kinases in short order is already gone
by the fact that we have a HTTP endpoint
on top of it the good thing about SNS
then is because we have SNS provides you
out-of-the-box message filtering so if
there is a consumer that is only
interested in orders for Canada we can
monkey nurses configure the subscription
for this consumer to all
receive orders for these type of events
following these methods attributes so
they don't have to care about the fact
that we have ten million order events
maybe for Canada it's just one thousand
and maybe they will only be they will
only receive the load for one thousand
so it reduces the complexity on the
consumer part another fact for choosing
SNS is the is because scaling up kinases
is harder or you have to scale kinases
as the amount of consumers grow in order
to make sure that that the fraud put is
at certain level so the more consumers
you add the throat boot is divided right
and then you have to add more salt to
the kinases in order to keep up with a
certain throughput and this doesn't
happen with asanas basically and the
third or the last reason why we decided
to choose asanas is because it allows us
to provide to the consumers two
different ways of consuming the data
push and pull both via HTTP so we can
create a subscription on SNS
and whenever we push our message to the
SNS as Ana's Wilson HTTP request to the
consumer or pool using SQL is like a cue
same as RabbitMQ or other cues that
exists an open source so whenever we put
a message with an S if the subscription
is meet ask us as SNS will write their
message into the queue and the consumer
will pull from the queue whenever they
want this is just so many of it so SNS
HTTP posed as an SPS pool so how we do a
stream a creation or ice also on
previous slide it was called enrichment
actually what we are doing here is more
close to enrichment
what we call by in Richmond or a stream
aggregation is just join in to a streams
so imagine we have on one side one topic
two topics one for order event so
when an order is placed another topic
for order esta to Saban's
when the status of the order changes
right we have two topics let's imagine
that now we have a consumer that wants
to consume data that combines both so
whenever we have an order status event
they want to also have the order even
right that would be the SNS topic on on
the right side so how we implement it on
our case is whatever your that event we
get into the topic we have a lambda
listening to these SNS and storing the
order with the reference order ID on
DynamoDB DynamoDB is no sequel database
we same as MongoDB and a good part of
DynamoDB is that the scales up
automatically up to the rich sunrise you
want so it's very convenient for us so
order which is the SNS lambda rising to
DynamoDB now whenever we have a northern
state to see band on SNS we a store on
SQL i'm from there is our Q the Q and
from there we have a lambda reading the
message from this queue checking e we
have this order on dynamodb if we have
it we combined the ban and we push
through this topic if we don't have it
this lambda can take back the event on
the queue and we process in seven second
in several seconds or minutes the reason
for this is because we have to deal with
the fact that things might come out of
order so it might be that we might have
an order status event but we still don't
have an order because they didn't come
so that's the reason for use in the
queue okay now the other capability that
we had to implement is to allow
consumers to pull the data via rest
interface how we implemented very simple
we have already there's an S topic we
trigger a lambda we store the data in
DynamoDB that i already
that scales automatically and on top of
it we just put a PA gateway endpoint to
read from there
we have a queue called that letter Q in
the Amazon terminology in order to have
retries in case there there might be
some network issue or things like that
so is used in order to have a higher
consistency in case things go wrong so
this by using these components we don't
have to scale anything these words if
you have 10 events or if you have 10
million events it will just be processed
busy you will have to pay more to Amazon
they will be happy but unless you were
really happy as well because you will
not have done times and things just run
okay now the last capability the
analytical capability so as I told you
is we needed to allow basically our
consumers to run queries that will
analyze huge amount of data so typically
we will need an OLAP DB right what we
decided to use this will be query
because it scales automatically
basically it doesn't scale you don't
know it's just the interface for your
consumers to run these analytical
queries Google bigquery will just handle
it regardless if you have ten megabytes
or hundred terabytes you will just pay
for that how we implemented is again we
have the event on the cns pipeline and
then we have a lambda reading from there
and then putting the event to bigquery
using the bigquery streaming API very
simple and again having the letter Q in
case maybe bigquery how might have
issues or some network things and so on
so just to make sure that the
consistency of the data will be high and
that there will be no data loss
so again these by using these components
the the doesn't matter the volume of
your data is just scaled up
automatically okay we also use bigquery
for data visualization of course the
fact that we have already all depends
there and it also allows us to use
looker or data studio or any of these or
tableau or any of these technologies
that build rapport on top of your data
ok so to wrap it up on top on the top of
this I will have the producer sending
the data to ingest an API from there
that it reaches the streaming part that
gets the data into SNS and then from SNS
we can provide data in three different
ways first use case near-real-time with
push pull second use case is providing a
restful api for the consumers that don't
want to have the data they just want to
pull it and the third use case is for
these teams that want to analyze huge
amount of data or text talk is nothing
really fancy I already mentioned the
data management solutions in the middle
but on the back end we use for
programming languages Java and
typescript is hot rabbits love nothing
fancy 12:06 way is raise the APM for
lambda you can also use theta doc we
might use theta top for the cloud watch
locks and a strike driver from on the
Google cloud site on the infra said we
use telephone to deploy or
infrastructure in Amazon and Google at
the same time we as a few weeks ago we
started using a lot this is this island
I can you see is used we use it in order
to deploy telephone from github
basically it's very nice it provides you
a very nice output of the changes on
every pull request so if you are using
the reformed and you have it you are not
using a lot this recycled is really cool
so what are the
challenges of that will have faced
during this one year I have first of all
is defining a slice so the fact that we
use cloud services and the fact that
they don't provide the salaries for the
latency or the durability means that we
cannot do it right because we are using
them what we have done is we created a
service that is pushing data on a stayin
on production and then dummy data of
course and then from the measuring was
the latency if there is any data loss
and then based on historical metrics for
for these things then we can ensure some
certain at some certain level was the
latency of the whole pipeline or if
there is any data loss basically so we
are instrument in ourselves second
challenge is the data quality so the
fact that we have an API endpoint that
is ensuring that the data is following
certain schema and is ballot because we
we have constraints like maybe email
phone number and things like that so we
have to ensure that this data is valid
but at the same time might be that the
data is rejected so how to find a
balance between rejecting data and
having some data that is partially
invalid so that was one of the
challenges at the moment we are just log
in on creating reports and on that is a
challenge we face another challenge is
the data documentation by this I mean
having a proper tool that exposes what's
the meaning of our data what data we
have how this data is linked to data on
other teams typically metadata there are
open source solutions that like Apache
allness or Amazon and Google they
provide their own we decided to use
Apache ala the open source one because
it's more has more
and what we are doing is we are
exporting bigquery metadata so the
tables the columns the type of the
columns if they have descriptions on the
on the metadata we import that into
Atlas and we provide this as a UI for
the teams using our data and unless if
we import also metadata from other teams
unless we could also link our data with
other data so this might was optimized
the time has been by your data engineers
searching for the rate not trying to
understand eternal third challenge GDP
are of course I don't think I need to
explain more you have to be compliant is
the law for one automating new pipeline
so the fact that we have such
distributed architecture with so many
components and all makes it harder to to
create new pipelines from the scratch is
same as with a macro service
architecture so the more components you
have the harder is to play them and the
last one is automating SNS subscriptions
so also how to deal with so many
consumers with managing the filters how
to deal with these kind of things that
take Indian f4 from our side and we want
to automate and these type of things as
much as possible yeah that's it
we are hiding we are a team of five
engineers so if this is of your interest
please send your application or talk to
me that's it I'll be now answering to
your questions and I guess there will be
office hours as well so yeah thank you
I have a question regarding the database
why you haven't choose a red shift for a
tina gimmick that you are all everything
is on AWS yeah question first of all
because redshift doesn't scale
automatically so you will have to assign
the nodes and have this headache or
maybe wake up on the middle of the night
because details broke the trust and why
not Athena which is more server less
because the simplify capabilities for
updating and deleting the data which are
needed for GDP I it's not that it
doesn't provide it you have to implement
it basically it's not that I think
provides you update or delete SQL
queries hi nice demonstration of your
process I see that every procedure I
mean it's very clear you are utilizing
or processing huge amount of data I also
see that in each one of your procedure
or process I see a table as lambda as
common element right yeah but lambda has
its own constraints like memory
constraint time constraints has lambda
been never an issue this time and memory
constraints an issue for you in any of
the process we for us is running
smoothly have you consider of course
hard limits like if you have a huge
amount of a huge spike of load lambda
has some limits in that sense but same
as if you are running your cluster right
you're running your cluster and you have
huge spike your cluster doesn't scale in
microseconds right or milliseconds even
on second so right nice presentation
thank you
Havas your decision process to come to
choose the use of all these cloud
infrastructure or cloud services
actually versus role in your
like it's using connexxus instead of
Kafka using lambda instead of some
hosted processor streaming processing
engines yeah the reason is that given
that we use cloud services then we use
these cloud applications or tools
because it's less having Indian to
maintain so for us is killing up kinases
is just updating one value and then
Amazon deals with the resort in keeping
with the notes running while resort in
making sure that the restarting is not
in an endless loop and this type of
things that I heard from for example on
the previous presentation is something
you don't have to deal with if you are
using kinases for instance something
that Amazon is already doing it for you
yeah so that's we try to use these cloud
tools as much as possible because of the
advantages that brings in some cases
might be a limitation maybe you want to
there is a hard limit on kinases for
example storing the data for more than
seven days that's a hard limit if you're
Kafka if you need to store today the
data in the event source database for
more than seven days then you need
something else one of the points you
explained it was about delays and how to
reach them especially for latency and I
thought that was particularly if you
were running infrastructure versus using
their their service interesting thank
you yeah thanks for the presentation I
just was triggered by one of the things
that you said that should not carry
about order and especially the dead
leather queues you might have like some
messages that are quite delayed I was
wondering if like the consumers of the
data ever had any problems around
dealing with the lack of order yeah so
we are monitoring delay the delay of the
events so we are receiving on the event
that timestamp when the event was
generated we are checking was a delay
between when the event reached our tool
versus when the platform said that it
happened basically so we are at the
moment just winner South monitoring but
we can easily create alerts and things
around that yeah hi so do you have any
additional comments regarding the data
transfer costs between AVS and cloud
because is the amount data not that big
or because the for us that was the main
blocker to use to switch between to use
like both cloud providers for us at the
moment is not an issue but as soon as we
see on our impact cost that we are being
huge amount of money for this we might
think about it I think it's also how you
have negotiated with Amazon these kind
of things or Google or both and I'm not
a word but at least on our introduced is
not huge hello
great talk I just so for example you
were mentioning about quality checks
complex validation how you use API
gateway for that you also mentioned
about the different brands that that you
end up supporting so how do you handle
for example custom data that specific
brands still want to do reporting on
that does not align to your sort of core
message model yeah in that case we just
had it as optional if there is piece of
information that is needed for some
consumers that is only produced in Korea
by yo-yo and not in Europe then we just
add it as optional field
you
[Music]